thank you again for doing my pilot you
did me a solid nobody ever sees the
pilot so you did it just to be kind nice
I think your friend I love you even it
was a year and a half ago it was a long
time ago yes it actually was a very hard
in it you my very first interview I told
this in I ran into you but like my your
book this is me is all about your dad
and like things about your childhood we
have very similar traveling yeah my
father had died like literally a day
before this interview and so I was like
sitting there trying and none in my crew
knew so I was literally they were like
we really want to ask and I'm like I
think we're good yeah I was like I think
we're good I think we've covered it and
I why'd we keep these emotions right
here you and I yeah so I was like you
know let's just bury you and then we'll
get back to it but no but thank you so
much I know you're so busy it was a very
kind thing to do I'm busy I don't know
how you you aren't busy too ma'am well
you are very kind of busy ish compared
to you know you're very nice but no what
was your worst haircut as a trial well
here's the thing it wasn't an accident
I wanted a rat tail got a rat tail oh my
god it's a rare statement that you heard
someone say I wanted arrived I was in
fourth grade wasn't like last week I was
in fourth grade and I was like this is
so cool and I could breed it like nobody
else had a rat til I was like I am
cutting-edge you were I sure was
yes you were country before country was
cool it was like a bull cut it was
didn't quite much I have the bowl that
was my worst yeah it was like literally
my mom claims that my hair just hadn't
grown it was just coming out like that
but it looks like a bowl cause an
accident yeah okay right yeah yeah and
then I did the whole like you've seen
like they shave the head like the back
of the head my sit I shaved the whole
side before but my sister and I was
young in the 80s I was really big right
people used to shave the whole back so
keep the top yeah I did that in the
other school my sister did that she's
cooler than oh cool but I wasn't that
cool I wasn't either but I pretended so
we have so many similarities but if you
had like a ton of jobs like before
success I did as well
yes yeah I liked how many are what was
your like most fun or worst or what um
well I of course I worked at McDonald's
I sold like sort of teeth straightening
things and I was always in the back
drive-through at McDonald's so like
every job was always about like being
congenial and like talking to people
yeah but
gosh I taught preschool for five years
and that was so much fun I didn't know
that sir ago oh yeah yeah that kind of
sounds like my personal hell like that
love children we have for but that if my
mom was a teacher and I used to sit on
her classes and I vowed to never be a
teacher
well 23 of them yes there's so many of
them and they're all visually one of you
right yeah and guys they're trying to be
themselves and fellow existing with
other kids it was really it was so much
fun but it was super challenging but
very fun so have your southern raids
helped you in this industry at all you
think I think you know I think in the
South people treat people kindly yeah
and I think that kind of folds over into
everything yes and you know how you
treat people is really the most
important thing in life yeah but I think
also there's southern charm I mean you
have it
I just fuses and my you have to have it
sometimes or play the dumb card right
well when you're like oh bless their
home yeah bless your heart and you just
really want to talk crap about your like
people they're like you know cut you off
in traffic
yeah yeah but you know I just try to I
mean my step daddy who I call country
come to town he would always say really
sweet things that like would encourage
you and support you and he would always
say this one phrase it's a sad day when
a frog cannot brag about his own lily
pad so what does that mean I love it
right right
what cuz he doesn't have a little about
what it no it means that like you should
be confident in who you are right
dealing yeah so brag about your own lily
pad
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this